begin in the United States where the
committee investigating the January 6
attack on the capital has accused the
former president Donald Trump of
dereliction of Duty for failing to call
off the riot investigators Drew on
testimony from Top White House aides who
described the president's inaction for
nearly three hours during the assault on
the capital through security footage and
recorded interviews with those in the
White House at the time the panel argued
that Trump gave a green light to the
violence president was speaking at the
rally the hearing also saw never but
seen before video showing Donald Trump
refusing to say that the 2020
presidential election was over the art
takes from his address filmed on January
7th last year showed the president
modifying the script
I would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
and to those who broke the law
you will pay
you do not represent our movement you do
not represent our country and if you
broke the law
can't say that I'm not I already said
you will pay the demonstrators who
infiltrated the capital
have defied the seat of decisions it's
defiled right see I can't see it very
well okay I'll do this I'm going to do
this let's go but this election is now
over Congress has certified the results
I don't want to say the election's over
I just want to say
Congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
about Congress is sort of now Congress
yeah right now Congress I didn't say
over so let me see
don't go to the paragraph before
okay
I would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
's a hard word for me
uh good take the word yesterday because
it doesn't work with
the heinous attack
on our country say own our country
want to say that no
No my only goal was to ensure the
Integrity of
my only goal was to ensure the Integrity
of the vote
earlier I spoke with our correspondent
in Washington sumisoma Scandal on what
consequences if any the committee's
investigation might have for Donald
Trump
well president Trump has from the very
beginning disparaged and discredited
these hearings he's delivered these long
tirades on his social media platform to
Social and he did that again on Thursday
as for the consequences that is a big
question of debate here in Washington so
this committee is not pursuing actual
legal action that is not in its purview
that has to come from the Department of
Justice and we have seen members of this
committee say they believe in no
uncertain terms that the chain of
responsibility for what happened before
January 6th and on January 6th leads all
the way up to the president that he knew
the election wasn't stolen that he tried
to coerce election officials and that he
incited that Riot but whether that means
that we would actually see President
Trump in court that's trickier because
the Department of Justice has to weigh
up whether all of this evidence that the
committee has presented would actually
hold up in court under cross-examination
and Anthony just imagine a jury being
selected for such a trial in what is an
incredibly politicized environment here
in the U.S all that being said many
observers here believe that all of the
evidence that's been presented has been
so damning that the Department of
Justice will have to do something so we
could possibly see Donald Trump facing
illegal consequences so part of that
political environment Zumi elections on
the horizon where does this leave the
Republican party right now
it's an interesting question because
the majority of Republicans have
completely rejected these hearings
they've called them political theater a
Witch Hunt they want hearings on
inflation instead issues more relevant
to the American people and Fox News
which I mentioned earlier the main news
channel for the right wing hasn't shown
the hearings live in their entirety but
we have seen a good number of
Republicans mentioned even implicated in
these hearings and we are quietly seeing
some members of the party trying to put
some distance between themselves and the
former president so these hearings could
impact the direction in which the Party
heads
in Washington thanks so much